and i better keep he's fortunate in his
own right to go out there and get that
20 the start of the season it's a big
start for him too leading into this
postseason a lot of questions around
who's going to be that third starter
maybe an opportunity for him to go out
there and finish his season strong
no surprise mark cannon gets hit who
knows
all is right
in the universe
and now pender
into center field chaz mccormick lines
it up
that'll do it for the a's in the first
inning southpaw swerving cole irvin
making his 32nd and final start of the
season
ground ball to short one hop and cosmos
got it flipped at first in time and
irvin works a one two three bottom of
the first and after one the a's and the
astros no score
to the second there's no score in
houston the is coming up against their
kitty
that one's hit deep to right field and
that baby's gone
seth brown on a one-two pitch homers for
the 19th time and the a's have a
one-nothing lead
flex on him mccormick would like to get
to 50 rbis if he can as you can see that
49 run batted in mark is seventh in the
rookie class in the american league
chaz goes to deep right field this could
be rbi number 50 on the home run by chaz
mccormick
14th home run of the year jazzy fizz
ties up the game at one i'm just gonna
let you keep making calls if guys need
to get the numbers they need to listen
to todd
here's tony kemp tony a fly ball to
centers first time a four hit game last
night for the first time in his career
here's the 1-1 and that is hit toward
left
back goes brantley at the crawford boxes
and then it goes to the boxes for tony
kemp it's a career high with eight home
runs for tk
and the a's back ahead two to one what a
season for tony kemp for the athletics
the mighty might has come through yet
again
bottom of the third inning oakland leads
2-1 it's been all solo homer so far in
this game
jake myers oh my goodness up on the
train tracks
the sixth train has just left union
station to tie the game up at two
that's by far his longest home run as a
major leaguer
old hits a fly ball to left field
michael brantley has to move just a few
steps back
and a good inning for jose or kitty it's
his first one two three inning of the
day pereira leading off for the
athletics against rakiti in the first
pitches of breaking ball slap to left
toward the line that's going to get down
for a hit bradley plays it back and
barrera holds with his second major
league hit
that's a base hit left center field
pereira's got good speed he'll wheel
around second and head to third so the
a's have first and third and nobody out
in the top of the fifth his first major
league hit man that has to feel good
since 2018
so first and third nobody out and tony
kemp is fly to center and homer he's
sitting with his average at exactly 280.
kemp hits a high fly ball plenty deep
mccormick goes back he's got it
both runners are going to tag barrera
will score and hustling into second
cosmon he gets in
swing at a miss
jose or kitty picks up a strikeout to
end the inning couple of singles
and a sac fly result in a run for the
a's and they are on top three to two
first mark issued by irvin
[Applause]
[Music]
cosman's got it cosmic the second for
one kemp on the first nicely turned by
tony kemp and that's a six four three
double play
[Music]
that one off the glove
of the first baseman seth brown but that
was a shot by jake myers could very well
be his second hit of the game
here's the pitch and that swung on and
popped up
foul territory right side brown has a
play near the box seats and he makes the
catch in the inning is over and after
five complete the athletics lead the
astros 3-2
here's a slowly hit ground ball to the
left side nice play on the move oled
miss diaz that's not an easy play oled
miss heading seth brown for out number
two
i think he wouldn't mind setting his new
career mark here to try and tie the game
up
drills one to left this one's going to
be on the line though didn't have enough
elevation altuve will take a double out
of it jose altuve having a nice series
against the a's he's now five for his
last eight
didn't matter as cole irvin ends up
snapping off a breaking ball to correa
for he gets the strikeout
it'll take a two out hit by kyle tucker
tucker at 29 home runs and 90 runs
batted in
tucker drives one deep to right field
number 30 on the year the astros lead
four to three
tk you're finishing strong
kyle tucker have a season 30 home run
season for kyle tucker what a year how
about zach cranky coming out of the
bullpen for the seventh inning blummer
almost 500 starts in between relief
appearances
got him
zach is going to get a nice hand heading
back to the dugout after his first
relief appearance since 2007 as he gets
a one two three inning here in the
seventh
that fall tap towards the left side and
that'll be booted a little bit by chad
kinder
3-1 pitch misses to castro so jason that
counts as a close and late big ovation
for jose altuv van what could be his
final at bat of the 20-21 regular season
altuve tries to drive one deep to left
field bidding four extra bases off the
scoreboard one run will score castro
will be held up altuve
on rbi double back-to-back doubles
carlos correa i'll just let you listen
in as he gets introduced for the final
time in the regular season of 2021.
[Applause]
live ball deep right field did he do it
to the wall that post gone number 26 on
the year
and probably his final regular season at
bat of 21 and the astros that lead six
to three
he loves the big moment so that was a
big one
carlos correa is going to come out of
the game marwin's going to move to short
and i'll just let you enjoy this moment
[Applause]
so pender with a base hit to right and
that'll bring up brown
brown hits one deep to right field down
the line and that baby's gone
seth brown gets to 20 home runs
with a two homer game on the season's
final day now it's six to five here's
chris davis pinch hitting
deep to left field
did he get enough
that baby is gone we're tied at six the
crusher
i told you we were not gonna live in a
world in which chris davis put an
oakland a's uniform on and did not hit a
bomb kite and we're not waking up in
that world tomorrow
there's a base hit
add to those light and close numbers
jason castro what a season
[Applause]
that ball drilled deep to left center
field all the way back martay he'll
watch it off the wall castrol great read
he'll be held up at third jordon alvarez
a double who else would you rather have
up needing a runner to score from third
with less than two out
there it is line drivers left field ball
game over the american league
batting champion for 2021 julie guriel
wins it with a walk-off single to left
[Applause]
you